when I talk to global leaders and
regulators around the world they're
focused on the outcomes instead of the
primitives being used to build these
technologies we have to focus our
regulation around the primitives being
used and how things are built rather
than just putting band-aids over the
outcomes you know these algorithms are
going to start making more and more of
these decisions and they're not being
built in such a way that it's required
that they explain why that would be one
you know one simple piece of regulation
is it so field of research and they I
call the explain ability really hard to
do but even small steps we take there
would be meaningful
why did my watch just tell me to stand
you know just just basic things because
we're offloading more and more of our
decisions to these algorithms and like
you've all said in this book if we don't
understand why we're doing it and why
they're making these decisions we've
just you know we've basically giving up
our agency completely why did I turn
left just that